what's up everyone welcome back to my
channel Richard on data if you're new
here my name is Richard and this is the
channel where we talk about data data
science statistics and programming
subscribe for all kinds of content just
like this and hit the notification bell
so you never miss an update so we're
gonna talk about graphs today because
seriously who doesn't love graphs and
data visualization graphs and data
visualization really are some of my
absolute favorite things in the data
science world but there's a right and a
wrong way to do them so if we're going
to do them at all we might as well do
them right so in this video I'm gonna
talk about some of the intuition around
why you want to communicate with graphs
in the first place some of the kinds of
graphs that you want to stay away from
it all costs and then some of the 2d
graphs which are generally good things
like column or bar charts histograms box
plots line charts scatter plots and pie
charts except for pie charts those are
usually not any good at all but we'll
get to that later
first of all the basis for using graphs
in the first place is to communicate
large amounts of information we want to
communicate more than just one single
data point and really the only other way
of doing this is with tables now graphs
are actually going to be worse than
tables if you care about precise and
exact values in that case you might just
be over complicating things and you'll
be better off just making a simple table
similarly if you have a bunch of
different groups or different variables
and they have all kinds of different
units or different scales to them tables
are probably going to be your friend as
well however if you're comparing sets of
data there's some kind of pattern or
some kind of trend that you can
communicate through that graph and
you're not boggled down with all this
stuff like different units or anything
like that
graphs are beautiful if they're done
correctly and they will be your friend
in that case so without further ado
let's look at some examples of graphs
which are just awful so if you look at
the example over here this graph is just
an unmitigated disaster so the
underlying data are actually pretty
simple but you can tell that they were
going for
3d graph for this just for cosmetic
purposes but it just makes it harder and
more confusing for the end user which is
you the reader if you look at the values
on the bottom right corner you can't
even really see where they stack up or
tell what they really are
now the creators of this graph it's
maybe not as exciting but they would
have been much better off just doing a
2d graph just doing like a column or a
bar chart with some of the different
categories side by side now we move on
to an even worse example so if we look
over here we've got a pie chart sort of
thing and already you shouldn't use a
pie chart if there's any other options
available to you but this just takes it
to the next level you've got a 3d effect
when you don't need one it's not adding
anything to the story behind the graph
or communicating anything about the data
and then the size of the objects do not
vary in proportion to the size of the
actual data represented and what is the
never group is it the orange at the
bottom is it the blue part I couldn't
tell you there's a ton that goes into
making a good graph versus a bad graph
that's a subject for its own video in
and of itself for this one I just want
to focus on types of graphs before we
get into things like colors scales and
things of that nature I'll have a link
to an article from Business Insider in
the description of this video which will
include more examples of terrible graphs
but as a general rule more complex is
bad simpler graphs almost without
exception are going to be better you are
not going to gain anything by trying to
impress your reader with all these
pretty visual effects you're just making
it more likely that you're going to
confuse them and if you think about
packages like ggplot2 and are they all
operate through what's called a grammar
of graphics framework now what this is
is it takes any kind of graph and it
breaks it down into simple components
you have a data component you have some
kind of geometric object so for a bar
chart that would be your bars for a
scatterplot that would be your points
and then you have some kind of
coordinate mapping system you're mapping
some variable to an x-axis some variable
to a y-axis and honestly this is the
best kind of graph most of the time
because they're simple and easy to
understand now there are absolutely
instances of great 3d graphs they're
visually appealing well-designed easy to
understand appropriate but generally
when possible you want to go with the
simpler 2d graph option so I'm gonna go
through some simple examples of the
graphs I mentioned earlier in this video
I'll go through each and describe the
circumstances when that kind of graph is
appropriate let's start off with column
and bar charts here's a column chart
this is from the MT Carr's dataset in
our column and bar charts are used for
summarizing categorical data typically
by way of things like counts or
percentages now if we flip this thing on
its side we'll have what's called a bar
chart
we're summarizing the exact same data in
a very similar type of way all that
we're doing is orienting things
horizontally instead of vertically now
you might be asking the question when
should you use a bar chart versus a
column chart honestly most of the time
you can get away with either they're
relatively interchangeable having said
that there are some best principles and
practices a bar chart is going to be a
little bit better in a few instances so
let's say you have a lot of really long
labels it can get really messy and
jumbled together if you cluster them all
together at the bottom whereas if you're
reading them all on the left-hand side
that just looks a lot better and a lot
cleaner then similarly if you have a lot
of categories it's gonna look a little
bit more natural seeing them all from
top to bottom as opposed to having this
graph which is just stretch really far
from left to right however there are
also instances in which a column chart
will be better so if you want to
accentuate a large value maybe sort your
data from largest to smallest reading
that from left to right is going to look
a little bit more natural than from top
to
bottom also humans tend to see sequences
from left to right so if there's any
kind of sequence to your data which
there kind of is here because I had
gears three four and five again a column
chart is gonna look a lot more intuitive
and natural you also have some
flexibility here for extensions suppose
if there's another variable that you
want to summarize so here's an example
over here we're going to add another
variable carb so now we have two
variables on the x-axis we have carb and
we have gear and we just put them side
by side we can do this with bar or
column charts and similarly we could
create a stacked bar or stacked column
chart if we have some kind of meaningful
part-to-whole
relationship next is histograms now
these are very similar to column charts
the only difference is these are used
for summarizing quantitative that is
continuous rather than categorical data
and we're doing the same thing in each
bin we have some kind of count or you
could summarize a percentage these are
also great for visualizing the shape of
a distribution just be careful with the
bin width here so you'll want to use
some kind of subject matter expertise
suppose the values 20 to 25 25 to 30
they're of particular interest to your
stakeholder you'll want to design the
histogram to accentuate that however
with the bin width just be consistent
with them don't have too many or too few
bins also have them be the same size
don't have a bin of with one next is
been with five and ten and twenty that's
just gonna get confusing just be
consistent with them now it's common to
see histograms smoothed out into what's
called a density plot here's an example
of the same data same histogram turned
into a density plot this is pretty
common however I would not recommend
representing your data this way unless
you have an absolute lot of it because
what you end up doing is losing the
ability to get precise and exact
numbers by bin or by group next box
plots now these are probably my personal
favorites this is an example from the
iris data set in R and the reason I like
these so much is because there's so much
information packed into them these are
used for summarizing the distribution of
a continuous variable and specifically
we're gonna get the minimum the first
quartile the median also known as the
second quartile the third quartile and
the maximum and the ggplot2 package in R
is really nice here because it's also
giving us what points in that
distribution are outliers and as you can
see here it's really natural if you want
to compare different groups to just put
them side-by-side
you're comparing that same variable
across different groups so easy so
natural so intuitive next scatter plots
and here's another example from the IRS
data set from R now the idea what the
scatter plot is you have two continuous
variables a scatter plot is useful for
visualizing the relationship between
those two variables it specifically
focuses on the relationship it's not
particularly good at illustrating the
distribution of either variable I
particularly love these because it can
sometimes be helpful if you have a lot
of different continuous variables to
just create what's called a scatter plot
matrix so for every combination of
variables you'll have a little
individual scatter plot and these are
really helpful this shows up all the
time and feature engineering and machine
learning work because you can very
quickly visualize relationships between
tons and tons of different variables
next up line charts here's an example
over here these are pretty straight
forward all this is doing is you have a
continuous variable and you are
visualizing how that quantity changes
over some kind of sequence almost always
that's just time and it's also totally
natural if you want you don't have to
have just one variable on the y axis
you can communicate multiple variables
in the same line chart just
differentiate between them with colors
and a legend simple straightforward
intuitive last on the list is pie charts
now these are usually terrible and
something that you want to avoid at all
costs now the idea with a pie chart is
you can visualize how various categories
contribute to a whole in fact with the
example we gave earlier with bar and
column charts you had the various gear
categories from the empty cars data you
could use a pie chart in that specific
context here's the problem though your
eyes cannot easily detect relative
precise differences between
multi-dimensional objects like pie
slices in the same way that you can
detect the differences in size between
columns and bars you can look at bars
and call them side-by-side and say yeah
that one's twice the size of that one
that is way harder to do with pie slices
see this example here notice that's
really difficult to tell the relative
difference in size between these
categories what if I told you that
category 3 was 3 times the size of
category 5 you weren't able to tell that
from looking at the graph were you were
you don't lie to me so that covers all
the core 2d graphs and like anything
else when you have data or some
information that you want visualized you
have to ask yourself the question of
what the purpose of the analysis is in
the first place so first of all do you
have categorical or quantitative data
after that do we want some summary
counts do we want to see the actual
distribution and get information about
it do we want to detect a relationship
do we want to detect a trend just basic
questions like that let me know in the
comments section down below what your
favorite graph is thanks for watching
this video until next time Richard on
data